the actual statement of chain rule is
you want to find a derivative of some
function y that has lots of X's in it
and the way you do that is you chain
together a bunch of related derivatives
we restate the original function in
terms of some u we introduce the
substitution and then we also
differentiate that introduced thing that
substitution itself we put those two
rivers together in this linked chain and
then we get the actual derivative we
want because these do use cancel now
what we did earlier this morning was we
did this formally we would say let u
equal and we did this whole step we did
all the working ok however if we know
just underneath where you've got that
right let's just consider the fact that
we can actually do this without having
to if we once we feel comfortable
without having to go through all this
process if we're happy to do it
comfortably in our heads just like
you've gotten more comfortable with
doing say X to the power of 9 like you
can do that without having some stuff
written down you can say the derivative
of X to the 9 is 9 X to the 8th you're
like oh I've done this for a few days
I'm comfortable okay here's where you're
going to get up let's consider y equals
something like let's go at X cubed plus
X to the we just said 9 right let's just
graph at night ok now we will come to
the point where we can differentiate
this with the chain rule dy on DX
without really having to think hard
about formally introducing that
substitution here's the way I'm going to
suggest you do it ok those two
derivatives that you got here and here
they kind of refer to the outside of the
function something to the power of 9 and
the inside of the function this X cubed
plus X right so what I'm gonna do is
read this in fact I'm gonna get my other
color here put it over here and I'm
going to label these as the outside
function something what's happening on
the outside something's being raised to
the power of 9 and then there's the
inside function that's the thing that
you would have substituted in right so
let's do them one at a time when you've
got something raised to the power of
nine you guys just told me before
what happens to the nine comes at the
front first right there you've got well
in this case I've got this in here X
cubed plus X and then what happened to
the nine it just drops down to eight so
just look at what I did that is the
derivative of the outside something for
the power of nine becomes nine something
to the power of eight it could have been
axes it could have been used it could
have been teased could be anything right
there's the outside derivative and now
let's have a look at the inside that's X
cubed plus X tucked inside those
brackets here
can someone differentiate the inside
there for me hold on three carefully the
three comes out the first the front
first three X then it goes down and then
that's a plus one full stop end of story
that's the derivative now why do I have
this picture up here I wonder if you've
worked out by now right
essentially what we're thinking of is
you've got this big function on the
outside but then as you open it up you
just have like smaller functions kind of
tucked away in there
right I've only got one level inside so
it's like you open it up and there's one
in there but you could go further we can
we can and we will give you more
complicated functions where you just
have to go from the outside do that then
do the next layer in differentiate that
and then do the next layer in and then
differentiate that okay that makes sense
inside outside now I want to give you
guys the opportunity because we didn't
really we just kind of said here it is
to have a look at I think it's seven
eight I introduced seven day this
morning and I know it's a bit criminal
you know wearing the extension course
sorry guys
seven a is gonna have the chain room in
it so even if you're not like spec
nobody's finished seven day right now
unless you have like a million free
periods in between period zero now
you're probably still in seven D but I
still actually want you while this is
relatively fresh in your mind to have a
got these introductory questions in
seven eight you can you can come back to
seven day later on that's right for
homework so we're gonna have a look at
this
seven days way you're looking at right
now yes are what was the question
say that again
four oh right right right yes thank you
let me get rid of this so we've got some
space for over key repeated again very
good okay so if this is our function and
I'm gonna do it just like we did over
here right I'm going to first write this
in a nice form to differentiate so
instead of having this on the bottom and
write with the negative index you can
someone help me out what would be
negative you next bit negative three
very good so at this point I'm ready to
go I've got a thing on the outside an
outside function and then I've got an
inside function to them one at a time
let's do the outside what affected this
before have I can yeah I can just write
out the front okay and then I start to
process this guy over here I'm gonna
multiply by negative three like
suggested okay I've got this other thing
and then what happens to the power drops
down one so now I've just dealt with the
outside that's the outside function
there's something to the power of
negative three
now I deal with the inside what's the
derivative of the inside it's just three
so let's tidy this up a little bit for
starters I've got four times negative
three times three negative thirty-six
thank you and then I'm also going to
remember this morning I said if you got
handed something with no negative
indices it's kind of nice to hand it
back in the same form so that's why I'm
putting this guy right down the bottom
like so there you go all right